let's bring in Peter Schrager NFL
Network good morning football co-host
and Fox sports.com senior national
writer also seeing him on the sidelines
stirring games as well let me start with
that topic there Peter can you see is it
a fair question
I know maybe apples to oranges here but
could Brady surpass Michael Jordan sure
if he wins more than 6 he gets he's
surpass him I think it's all about the
rings right so if he has seven then he
can make the argument that I've done it
but we look at football differently than
basketball it's five on five the
athleticism that shows up with
basketball as opposed to Brady and
football and be in there with fellow
check
are we being fair to what Jordan did you
know I know the Brady is now and hey
he's got more titles therefore he's got
to be better and you know being in eight
Super Bowls if that were the case yeah
yeah and it wasn't long ago where Brady
hadn't surpassed Jill Montana oh I know
I know it wasn't long ago and you know
you would say that Jordan didn't
surpassed Muhammad Ali I feel like the
torch gets passed and if Brady wins more
championships in football and 11 on
Lannisport with longitude I would go
Brady and Jordan took two years off in
his prime sure did play baseball right
this is tweet you had would you rather
have Ben Roethlisberger's career or Drew
Brees his career huh and your answer was
Ben are you kidding me two Super Bowl
rings yeah I know but the first one you
know the e3 Super Bowl appearances Drew
Brees is know is a first-ballot
hall-of-famer one of those guys that
they'll introduct and say no argument II
did Drew Brees he's in Ben
Roethlisberger if I'm asking whose
career would I rather have who's a
better quarterback probably Brees yeah
whose career would you rather have
hydrate other have Brees the one yes
Super Bowl the one MVP he is New Orleans
yes yes and and that puts it over the
top because what he did when he did it
how he did it what it meant to that city
you know Ben will never surpass Terry
Bradshaw not so no matter what he does
he's never gonna equal Terry Bradshaw
where's you're gonna have a hard time
equalling drew brees passing numbers all
of that and yes winning the one Super
Bowl only one Super Bowl now if Drew
Brees had two Super Bowls we're not even
having the argument how different would
we
look at his career because then all of a
sudden is he better than Peyton Manning
and and it's crazy because you go
through the losses that Drew Brees has
had the beast quake run was against Drew
Brees the Alex Smith heroic touchdown
pass against the Saints in the division
against Drew Brees and then this one
boom it's a heck of a reel of Drew Brees
playing his butt off and getting beat by
these freak freak ways I don't know that
Sunday for Drew Brees to lose that game
it's one of the craziest things I've
ever seen
and the way he played in the second half
now he didn't play like a whole affair
on the first half but he played like a
hall-of-famer in the second half your
thoughts on you saw Sean Payton sort of
mocking the Minnesota fans they're the
skull chant in the final 30 seconds did
you see it
look I saw I saw it all online this is
Sean Payton he wears the black hat and
he is okay with that is the same Sean
Payton who did a choke sign at the
London Freeman brought up he's the face
Ron Rivera and the Panthers twice the
next several years he had no problem
bring out a broom on the Fox he doesn't
care he doesn't care and he embodies
that and guess what the team feeds off
him camara and Engram those guys talk
Kim Jordan great dude sportsmen all that
he talks they are what Sean Payton wants
him to be so if he wasn't gonna do that
kind of stuff it wouldn't be true to who
he is now the people think he's a jerk
around the league I don't know you can
find people who could think a lot of
people are you probably knew but that
kind of stuff isn't usually what we see
from a head coach that said the New
Orleans Saints there's 31 teams in the
league and then there's the New Orleans
Saints I kind of operate in their own
little district and that's how they
embody themselves and that's cuz they
had coach how many times do you see
something on the sidelines that you
don't report it's like constantly you
hear a conversation and it's debate of
what does the audience need to know most
of times I'll go to my producer and most
of times it does make air Ben Lieber is
a former Vikings linebacker he was doing
the Vikings radio on K FET and he's the
one who first spotted it and then the
fans had all these pictures that's not a
story unless it's a good sideline
reporter saying hey wait a second before
the biggest play of the game this guy
was celebrated or taunting or whatever
you want to call it as he said it was
just some fun but what other items could
you see on the sidelines that you
wouldn't report injuries injuries to a
point where the team says let's let's
get clarification
rush to say thing a lot of times these
guys use the restroom on the bathrooms I
don't think anyone needs to know what's
going on when they put the towel up over
them that's not that's not necessary to
the broadcast and other times there's a
lot of foul language being said and I'll
say had a heated exchange I have you
ever been privy to concussion protocol
myself no no no watching it we've
suggested that you be you know it's
funny concussion protocol yes last year
Carson Palmer went down in a game
against the Rams in like the fourth
quarter and I'm watching this thing all
go down and to their credit the
independent guys were like you're not
going in and Carson Palmer was like I am
fine like I need to go back in there
like you're not going into your Stan
comes in throws a pick came over and
Palmer was furious because he's like I'm
fine you can't so that kind of stuff is
really just it's a touchy area with the
NFL and when you play it on the cautious
side sometimes they ever hurts at Cam
Newton shouldn't go back in the game
well if gammy ones fine you'd rather
have Cam Newton in the final Drive than
Derek Anderson so it's a very
interesting debate and how those
interactions are and I like to keep an
eye on who's saying what and usually
they decide in the side of caution but
it's an inexact science and I understand
the player wants to go back in if I'm
the head coach I want my starting
quarterback back in there it's just you
know can you can you have a heavier fine
like what's the deterrent there when you
see these guys you know now cam has a
bad knee sure and then it was his I had
nothing to do with a concussion well you
saw Adam Schefter got pretty heated on
ESPN like the day after and was like you
know no more of this and then you know
the Seahawks Russell Wilson now it's a
charade what they did on that Thursday
night game against the Cardinals when he
kind of dipped in and came back out
they got levied a very serious fine for
that so the NFL is trying their hardest
to make this a high priority but in real
time you can't do a neurological exam
that is a hundred percent certain so
Russell Wilson to this day says I was
fine well well he's fine but then why
take a peek into I want to see what
you've really done some nice things with
this place in here
Peter Schrager NFL Network good morning
football co-host Fox sports.com senior
national writer convince me the Jags win
this game against New England they have
all the ingredients I've seen that they
see the Patriots
who's at home in the playoffs to the
Ravens what they have they had a fierce
pass-rush
and a fearless team that talked a lot of
smack I seen them lose at home to the
Jets what they have that Bart Scott Rex
Ryan fearless and fearless and then I
seen them lose to the Giants and it was
Justin Tuck and OCM anura and stray and
fearless and fearless those are the only
teams that beat the Patriots in these
games we have had a blast on our show
good morning football which is Jalen
Ramsey soundbites you know okay and it's
not just him telling Smith talks AJ boy
eh talks they all talk they believe it
they're young enough where they believe
they can win and they've got the secret
ingredient in Tom Coughlin who Dan I I
know you know this I'm close to a lot of
the Jacksonville guys this is not some
ornament some ceremonial thing this
isn't Bud Grant flipping the coin toss
before the game this guy is boots on the
ground and very involved he was very
involved with the hiring of Doug Marrone
and he's very involved with the players
all the way they practiced right down to
how they dress at practice the tone is
set from Tom Coughlin shod con saut Tom
Coughlin out for moments like these he
moved his entire life back down to
Jacksonville and he knows the secrets
and he knows how to get it done and they
have the ingredients they're on the
roster I think they've got a shot well
they have a shot because they get to
line up on the field with them it's just
is somebody gonna go out on the limb and
say the Jags are gonna win this game I
haven't yet okay I don't seem that
person I haven't either
yeah I'm just curious about them but
when you look at these quarterbacks here
I saw a lot of columns here even
commentary oh you don't need a franchise
quarterback here okay you still do
because Brady's the MVP
Carson Wentz got you to this point not
Nick Foles
Case Keenum is better than what people
yep you know and Blake bortles would be
the guy who's sorted the third overall
pick
yeah but he's sort of tagging a lot I
like that he's the highest drafted
quarterbacks are still left you know he
was carried by his deep defense and
Leonard fournette you know granted I'll
give you that but you still need I would
take my chances on a franchise
quarterback over you know a non
franchise quarterback yes absolutely and
it's it's why the NFL is so fun in the
NBA you know we could talk all we want
about the Clippers and rockets we know
at the end of the day the Warriors are
playing the Cavs in the final sorry
spoiler that's what it is the NFL this
is what happens right nick foles is
playing in a nasty championship game
against Case Keenum these guys were
teammates on a four and twelve Rams team
you know coached by Jeff Fisher so
that's
NFL and to me if you have that defense
and you have the quarterback room like
whence is still very much involved in
John Dee filippo and Frank Reich these
guys there's a it's not just foals
they're on an island it's got a great
defense he's got a great quarterback
coach in a great quarterback room
explained to me Josh McDaniels with the
Colt yeah okay I got a no Andrew Luck is
is gonna be healthy so when people tell
me hey he looks great
does he look great throwing a football
everybody said he looks great he looks
is eclis great yeah great six-pack I
don't care about that this seems like a
risky move for josh mcdaniels yeah um I
would say you'd want to know as much
information as you have on Andrew Luck
the problem is there just isn't that
information but would you rather have
the lineup all these open okay let's
rank the openings Giants huh Lions huh
I'm going Colts because Andrew Luck is
that much better because Andrew Lockett
name isn't good the golden goose a the
third overall pick Chris Ballard
respected and and this guy look the
they're dragging their feet both sides
on this one because this was something
I've been hearing now for a solid few
weeks hasn't been done yet and everyone
who thinks the titans is is not a the
Mariota and the titans is tempting also
so there's a lot of things with Josh
right now and then a hiring that's the
thing with the Titan you don't fire Mike
Mularkey unless you have some sort of
hope or plan in your back pocket I don't
think Matt Lafleur the offensive corner
from the Rams the answer I don't think
Frank Reich is necessarily the answer I
wonder if they give a godfather deal to
Josh McDaniels and say hey here's the
most money that you're gonna make and
all this stuff
Mariota that's not done yet my other and
this is not a conspiracy theory I mean
that's not reporting josh is dragging
his feet on this one because I believe
the Colts would love to have him and if
he doesn't take it Mike Vrabel will be a
very fine coach for the indiana post
coach i wonder and I haven't spoken to
Josh about this directly but I wonder if
he's wondering let's finish out this
season let's see how the Superbowl goes
and let's see if bill has made a
decision about his future eventually
somebody has to be the guy to replace
the guy it reminds me of a CEO who is
riding high 18 years Stockton and then
there's no succession plan right I mean
these guys keep on leaving Patricia's
gone and then McDaniels is gone
Belichick is a son on staff
is that the succession plan is there a
guy that he is anointed because a lot of
times you see that in the college game
especially your the coaching waiting
your the next guy
if McDaniels and Patricia leave who are
longtime coordinators who is the next
guy and and do you really think bell
chicken coach till he's 80 and 90
because if that's the answer fine I
guess it is but you also I look at Mike
Schuh chef ski the same way it's true
you know is it somebody on the staff
that they went on to get head coaching
experience so then when they come back
they are you know more viable to take
over for Kay so somebody's gonna
eventually be input put in that position
do you have playoff plans this weekend I
will be watching watches cannot wait for
that to be but will you wear a suit and
tie
yeah just on the couch I like that Peter
Schreyer NFL Network good morning
football co-host Fox sports.com senior
national writer thank you again for
stopping by we always appreciate it love
come on this is really cool for me for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]